Vsauce Kevin here with a deadly dice
game that from your perspective gives
you a ninety seven point two percent
chance of surviving but from your friend
Billy's perspective there's a 90 percent
chance that this game kills you how does
this make any sense well here are the
rules of our theoretical potentially
horrific game one person walks into a
room and rolls a pair of dice as long as
they don't roll double sixes they walk
out of the room alive and they win 1
million dollars the game continues but
this time 10 people walk into the room
and an appointed roller rolls the dice
and if they don't roll double sixes all
10 people walk out of the room alive and
with a million bucks each each round the
number of players in the room increases
by a factor of 10 so 1 10 100 1000
10,000 and so on each participant only
gets to play one round in as soon as
double sixes are rolled the game is over
forever also for this game we have an
unlimited supply of money and infinity
people because we're gonna get to 10
billion people by the 11th round and
that's more humans that we have on earth
Oh also we have a room that can hold
infinity people suspend reality when an
unlucky roller finally rolls double
sixes also called boxcars or midnight
everyone in that room dies instantly
kind of a grim game but a million bucks
is life-altering money so you may
determine that it's worth the risk
after all the odds of survival are in
your favor six sides on each of two dice
marked with dots officially called pips
means there are possible 36 combinations
you can roll that's a 1 in 36 chance
you'll roll double sixes which is only
2.7
seven repeating percent which will round
up to 2.8 percent to put it another way
there are 35 different combinations of
survived roles and only one combination
of death role you might think that the
game could be played for 18 rounds
before there was a 50/50 chance of
rolling double sixes because 18 out of
36 possible combinations is 50% right
well no that's actually not how we
figure this out in fact you'd have to
roll 25 times for a 50% chance of
rolling double sixes
thanks to combinatorial probability the
easiest way to figure this out is
actually to put the problem in terms of
success instead of failure so there's a
35 out of 36 chance that our roll will
let us survive to calculate the
probability of game players all having a
certain number of surviving roles we
raise 35 over 36 to the nth power where
n is the number of rounds the game is
played in five rounds the chances that
everyone survives are about 87% 10
rounds and Matt drops to 75% at n equals
18 rounds that are still a 60% chance
that no one has rolled double sixes it
isn't until the twenty-fifth round that
the odds shift against us
I mean you could roll double sixes on
the very first try it's just not very
likely but each player is only playing
one round and we know that 1 out of 36
is about 2.8 percent which means to you
the player you have a 97.2% chance of
living and getting the money whether
you're on your own in the first round or
in round 9 with ninety nine million nine
hundred ninety nine thousand nine
hundred and ninety nine other people but
when your friend Billy hears that the
game has finished and that you were one
of the players he knows there's about a
90% chance you're no longer in the
mortal realm
and he's understandably concerned after
all he is your best friend the reason
he's concerned is very simple despite a
2.8 percent risk of a dice rolling
fatality there's about a 90% chance that
you were one of the unfortunate recently
perished losers the danger is a matter
of perspective you know you've got a 97%
chance of surviving year round and
getting paid your risk of death by
double sixes is low but poor said Billy
realizes that because of each rounds
escalation of players the final group
that rolled double sixes and succumbed
to the deadly rules of the game makes up
almost 90 percent of all of those who
played so if you participated you are
likely in that group to Billy there is
only about a 10 percent chance you
survived your truth is that your chance
of surviving is extremely high
your friends truth is that the chance of
you being dead is nearly 9 out of 10 in
the double sixes death game reality
doesn't change but a person's
perspective can flip that probability on
its hips and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
I'm actually gonna go through all the
combinations right now just on the
camera okay so so we got one one one two
[Music]
and six
[Music]